ah les américains fêtent ce 4 juillet
l'anniversaire de la déclaration
d'indépendance de leur pays vis-à-vis de
la grande-bretagne joe biden accueille
pour l'occasion un millier d'invités à
la maison blanche
une journée que le président américain a
souhaité placer sous le signe du retour
à la normale pour les états unis
même s'il n'est pas parvenu à atteindre
son objectif de 70 % d'adultes
américains ayant reçu à ce jour au moins
une injection antico vide
la correspondance à washington de thomas
bonnin joe biden avait fixé cette date
du 4 juillet jour de la fête nationale
américaine comme le retour à une vie
normale il avait fixé un objectif
chiffré 70% de la population américaine
ayant reçu au moins une première dose de
vaccin mais cet objectif a donc été
manquée puisque selon les dernières
estimations des autorités sanitaires
seuls 67 % des américains ont à ce jour
reçu une première injection alors malgré
cet échec joe biden veut montrer qu'un
retour à la vie d'avant est possible
notamment donc avec cet événement
organisé au sein de la maison blanche
inimaginable il ya encore quelques
semaines mille personnes au sein de la
maison blanche a invité il s'agit de
travailleurs de première ligne de
militaires de leurs familles qui vont se
réunir autour d'un barbecue une garden
party où d'ailleurs il n'a pas été
demandé à tous les participants d'être
vaccinés mais en revanche seuls ceux qui
sont vaccinés pour ne pas porter de
masque pendant cet événement joe biden
qui affiche donc un optimisme malgré son
échec que cet objectif chiffré
écoutez cet extrait d'une vidéo postée
par le président américain sur son
compte twitter nous avons besoin que
tout le monde soit vaccinée si nous
faisons cela ensemble d'ici le 4 juillet
il y a de fortes chances que vous vos
familles et vos amis puissent y est
célébrée le jour de l'indépendance
ce qui fera de cette fête de
l'indépendance quelque chose de vraiment
spécial
ce 4 juillet l'amérique est de retour
malgré cet optimisme il y à l'inquiétude
autour du variant delta invariants plus
contagieux présent dans les 50 états du
pays et qui seraient responsables
aujourd'hui selon les dernières
estimations d'une contamination sur
quatre à travers le pays ce qui fait
redouter aux autorités sanitaires des
pics épidémiques localiser c'est surtout
que la couverture vaccinale est très
différentes selon les états sur les
côtes est et ouest et dans les grandes
villes globalement la plupart des
américains ont déjà été largement
vacciner mais dans des étapes plus
ruraux dans les états du sud comme
l'alabama le mississipi ou encore la
louisiane cette couverture vaccinale
frôle à peine les 40 % il ya en réalité
des récalcitrants parmi eux les
américains selon un sondage qui a été
publiée quelques jours 13 % des
américains estiment ne pas vouloir se
faire vacciner 7 % affirment qu'ils se
feront vacciner seulement si cela est
rendu obligatoire alors une obligation
de vaccination pour le moment ce n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour
joe biden ne souhaite pas imposer une
telle obligation de la part du
gouvernement fédéral mais il y à des
entités plus locale qui commence à
réfléchir sérieusement à cette
possibilité tout comme pour le retour
d'un certain nombre de restrictions le
port du masque n'est plus obligatoire en
intérieur pour les américains ayant été
vaccinées et bien certains comptes et
sont en train de revenir sur cette
mesure face à l'inquiétude générée par
l'émergence du variant delta c'est le
cas par exemple du comté de los angeles
qui recommande désormais très vivement
le port du masque à l'intérieur et y
compris pour les américains ayant été
vaccinées